early in the morning the circus is just
waking up let's go along and watch we
don't need any tickets now but we must be
sure to leave before the big show starts
before long from the set array but
right now all he wants is breakfast
jumbo when theythey get a fresh pail
of water instead of orange juice
are they thirsty
the pony gets a haircut and so does
his trainer everybody's cleaning up
look jumbo is getting a shower did
you ever see anyone enjoy a bath more
and now under the big top rehearsals
are starting first the jugglers this
always looks easy can't understand
why it never works when I tried
here comes thunder the Wonder horse takes
practice patience and a piece of sugar to
teach her the tricks that make her one of
the greatest circus horses in the world
now here's a really hard trick
walking backward on our hind legs
young acrobats have to learn their ABCs too
one two three back to the center ring where we
can see jumbo the elephant rehearsing Jumbo's the
special favorite of the boys and girls you should
hear them laugh when he answers the telephone
high up in the circus tent the flying
bananas are rehearsing their act
even when they practice they must be perfect
everything must be exactly right
I'm out for lunch nothing
much just the light snack
here comes the trainer to talk to his life
he's saying brown [ __ ] good boy good
fellow he uses kindness and gentleness
with his lions no commands no
chairs are no whip cracking
rehearsals are over under the big top
everyone is preparing for the great show
the arena is covered with sawdust
the clown's get ready
costumes are put on
they are ready to start and now it's time
for us to leave but we've seen a part of the
circus but no one with tickets ever gets
to see we've seen a circus come to life